abone ol
Selam
[Müzik]
[Alkış]
bugün size her yolculuk geçmişten başlar
temalı bir konuşma yapacağım ama önce
sormak istiyorum geçmişinden memnun
olanlar kimler
O benim çok güzel bir geçmişim var çok
mutlu bir hayat yaşadım diye bayağı ev
kalkıyor diye görüyorum şu anda
o Yukarıyı tam göremiyorum ama
şimdi merak etmeyin geçmişe gideceğiz
ama benim geçmişim Sizinki de
gitmeyeceğiz Onun için kısa bir video
ile şu anda herkesi aynı anda toplamak
istiyoruz Benim çektiğim video biraz ona
bakalım ondan sonra üzerine konuşacağız
yok ama önce şunu sormam lazım size de
geriye dönüp baktığınızda kendinizi en
çok ne yaparken buluyorsunuz bu soruyu
aklımızda tutmamız rica ediyorum
konuşmanın sonunda tekrar soracağım
Çünkü cevabı çok önemli O verdiğiniz
cevap Aslında sizin hayata geliş
sebebimiz oluyor Evet başladı
adı Şimdi ben Denizi çok severim
çocukluğumdan beri İstanbul'a gelişimde
Aslında birazcık çocukken kurduğum Bir
hayalden kaynaklanıyor Çok küçük böyle
hatırlamayacağım kadar Küçük yaşlarda
boyum şu kazarken falan bir vapur
gezisinde İstanbul'a ilk kez gelmiştim
ve böyle rüzgarda saçlarım uçuşuyordu o
kadar heyecanlanmıştım Burası Harika bir
şehir Ben burada iyice bulayım diye
düşünmüştüm tabi aradan geçen yirmi
küsür yılda biraz size anlatacağım neler
olduğunu Aslında önce hayal ederek bir
şey 12 hayatımızda bu kardeşim ve ben
Ben beş yaşındayken o dünyaya geldi
aslında ortak olmak gibi bir planımız
yoktu ama Hayat öyle bir şekilde
ilerledi ki bir şekilde ortak oldum
hikayemizi dinlediğinizde umarım sizin
için de ilham verici olur benim
Çocukluğum biraz Biz hareket li geçti
ama kendi içimde Hareketli yani çok dışa
dönük bir çocuk değildim bu beni şimdi
bu da izleyenler varsa ne kadar çok
güldüğümü ne kadar Aslında iletişimde
güçlü olduğunu bilenler var ama tamamen
Aslında bireyselliğin dengeliyor bu yani
Mesela annem beni sokağa gönderirdi ben
hiç oynamadım hemen orada olmuş gibi
yapardım ve geri dönmenin bir yolunu
bulurdum ya bir kitap okurdum ya işte
kendi kendime yemek yapardım Bu benim
okuduğum ilk kitap İlkokulu henüz
başladığımda Nereden aldın Nasıl aklıma
geldi niye kuşlarla ilgili bir kitap
okumak istedim Çünkü aslında kuşlardan
korkuyorum bilmiyorum ok Evet ilk kitap
Aslında hayattaki duruşunu da çok belli
eden bir kitap yani yaptığımız seçimleri
bazen bilerek yapıyoruz bazen de
bilinçsiz bir şekilde yapıyoruz o
zamanlardan aslında hep özgür olmak ve
yalnız uçmakla ilgili bir isteğim varmış
şimdi Ankara'da Anıtkabir'de ziyaret
teyiz ben yine gitmişim bir aslanın
önünde oturmuşum Aslan burcuyum Hadi
benim fotoğrafımı çek diyor yani yine
sosyal değilim aslına bakarsanız çünkü
hep bir çaban var bir şeyler öğrenmek
ile ilgili bir şeyler üretmek ile ilgili
mesela ilkokulda tarifini bilmeden dolma
yapan bir çocuk düşünün gibi bu merak
beni Aslında hayatımda farklı yerlere
götürdü bu benimle ilgili
görebileceğiniz tek mezuniyet fotoğrafı
üniversite mezuniyetine maalesef
katılamadım ben bayağı iddialı bir
üniversite hazırlık süreci geçirdim
Diplomat olmak istiyordum ve
uluslararası ilişkiler tek tek istediğim
bölümdü ama o bir şekilde ol ve ondan
sonra da dedim ki ben artık şey yapmak
istemiyorum üniversite sınavına
hazırlanmak istemiyorum Birsen ara
verdim Sonra baktım hani bu çok böyle
Büyütülecek birşey değil yani üniversite
Ondan sonra dedim ki ben dış ticaret
okuyayım Çünkü burada işletme ile ilgili
bütün temel dersleri Alıyorum biraz da
kısa sürede bitiririm bazı yeteneklerin
de olduğunu düşünüyorum vesaire bir de
üniversiteye Ticaret okumaya başladım
Fakat o dönemde ekonomik durumumuz biraz
bozuldu ama ben özel okulda okuyorum bu
arada iyi olmaz Kıla çok özdeşleştiği
için değil Bu aslında mesela bazı
anektodlar vermek için Fortune dergisi
2007-2008 olması lazım Tam doğru yılı
Türkiye'de ilk sayısını çıkarttı Sabancı
Ailesi kapaklı böyle bir yağlı boya
tablo şeklinde ve ben o dergiyi
alabilmek için yaklaşık iki-üç hafta
para biriktirmiştir Yani o kadar bu
pratik bütçelerle hareket ediyorum benim
için önemli Olması Aslında sadece maddi
sıkıntılar yaşıyor olmam değil Hayatta
hep bir şekilde elde bulunduğum
kaynakları bir şey öğrenmeye kanalize
ediyor olma şimdi parçaları sonunda daha
net birleştirebiliriz ama aslında
yaptığımız hiçbir şeyi nedensiz
yapmıyoruz Okulu Okuyorum işte artık o
kadar riski bir duruma geldik ki
gidersem ciddi anlamda zorlanacağınız o
zaman ne yapayım Bir yıl doldurayım peki
okulda kaydı dondurdum ne yapacağım
çalışmam lazım işte İzmit deyim İzmit
miyim Ben Kocaeli'de bir yerel gazetede
bir ilan gördüm diyor ki satış
temsilcisi arıyoruz Aslında ben satışlı
aramda hiç iyi değildir ama gazete
olduğu için çok dikkatimi çekti bu o
gazetenin ilk sayısı ve ilk kapağı
gördüğünüz gibi dehşet verici ve üstüne
böyle bir sürü not almış Bak şimdi benim
her şeyi iyileştirmeye çalışmakla ilgili
bir çabam var kötü bir şey gördüm zaman
dayanamıyorum diyorum ki ya bu şöyle
olsa nasıl olur Bunu böyle yapmazsak da
böyle yapsak nasıl olur işte bu soruları
sormaya başladığım andan itibaren
fikirler gelmeye başlıyor bunları
insanlarla paylaştığım zamanlarda bir
etki alıyorum ben reklam topluyorum
bayağı Hiç ummadığın bir şekilde ama
gazetenin sahibi ne gittim Dedim ki
benim bazı fikirlerim var Bunları
uygulamak ister misiniz O da dedi ki o
zaman sen Genel Yayın Yönetmeni ol hep
ver dedim ki o kadar kolay genel
yönetmen oluyor mu ve Hadi bakalım dedi
çıkar kendi sayılır
şimdi o dönemde
2007 yılından bahsediyoruz orada sağ alt
köşede yer okuyabiliyorsanız şeyleri
görebilirsiniz Ben gitmişim Az önceki
kapaktaki gazeteye böyle bir şey haline
getirmişim attığı manşet ve ABD'nin
mortgage piyasası krizi metal bir
sonraki şeye bakalım başla bakalım
yoksulluk sınırı 2 bin 27 lira milletin
iradesini görmezden gelemem Çünkü ben
diyorum ki burası bir şey Sanayi kenti
bizim bu gazeteyi bir şekilde Ticaret
Odasına Ondan sonra işadamlarının
gündemine onların masalarına
toplantılarının gündemini sokmamız lazım
bunu yapmak için de belli şeyleri
bahsediyor olmamız lazım yani sadece
alışveriş Kocaeli'de yaşam şu bu olmaz
gazetenin sahibi o kadar iyi bir adamdı
ki 48 den sonrası çıkartmadı genel
Yönetmenlik hikayemde burada böyle bitti
eline çalışmam lazım biber zincirinde
çalışmaya başladım gördüğünüz gibi
burada çok mutluyum biraz zayıf olduğum
için olabilir
burada aslına bakarsanız çok şey
öğrendim yani ne kadar hızlı hamburger
yapabileceği ya da bir wukur yediğinizde
kaç gram mayonez kaç domates O denizin
haricinde aslında hızlı Tüketimin hayatı
içindeki farklı noktaları Fakat burada
Mesela bölge müdürüne diyordum ki
şunları şöyle yapmasak da böyle yapsak
nasıl olur şimdi bugün birazdan
anlatacağım şirketimiz var la Adem Fırat
isminde İstanbul'un en önemli Burger
zincirlerinden bir tanesini ve Global
açılacak Bir markaya danışmanlık veriyor
yani o zaman ben hamburger yapan bir
kızdım ama şimdi büyük bir hamburger
markasının danışmanı olan bir kızım sizi
üzmemek için bu kadar toplu bir görsel
koydum
hamburger hikâyesinden sonra bir 10 12
aylık
mağaza deneyimim oldu part time satış
danışmanı olarak girdim az önceki şeye
de Burger zincirle de parkta girmiştim
ayda 375 TL kazanıyordum 2007 yılında
bir baktım 14 yıl geçmiş Yani o
hayatımda geriye dönüp baktığımda
beğeniyorum kayıtlar yaşa bu işte çok
zorlandığımı düşündüm Neden bunları
yaşıyorum diye sordum zamanda üzerinden
tam 14 yıl geçmiş buraya da satış
danışmanı olarak girdim işte bir tezgah
düşünün üstünde tişörtler var siz sabah
güzel bir şekilde açıyorsunuz mağazayı
Ondan sonra orası bir pazar tezgahı gibi
bir yığın haline dönüşüyor orayı
toplamaya başlıyorsunuz içinden simitler
çıkıyor su şişeleri çıkıyor işte çeşitli
başka şeyler çıkıyor falan gibi sonra
bana burada bu mağaza mı kasasını teslim
ettiler dediler ki sen buranın kasa
yöneticisi ol ve bütün mağazanın
sisteminden yönetiminden sorumlu dedim
ki Tamam ve uzun bir süre burada önemli
tecrübeler edindim Çünkü perakende Bence
dinamikleri çok hızlı olan bir yer sonra
bir şekilde Okulu bitirdim Okulu
bitirmek için Bunun haricinde Geri
döndüğümde Az önce gördüğümüz gazete
burger ve mağaza o ara verdiğim İyi
o zaman da iki farklı İşte çalıştım
birincisi Psikologlar Derneği nde
psikologlara işte çay kahve servisi
yapmak İkincisi de ünlü Bir doktorun bir
projesini dinleyip ses kaydını edit
etmek o hikayede şöyleydi bir denizci
gemide bir iş kazası geçiriyor ve bütün
fonksiyonlarını yitiriyor konuşma hafıza
beyinler onların ı
tedavi eden doktor da Onu tedavi ediyor
bende 300 tane kaydı dinleyip Deşifre
etmekle görevliyim fakat Sorun şu ki
konuştuğunu yani O hasta olan kişinin
konuştuğunu sadece eşi anlayabiliyor bir
300. kadın sonunda artık ben adamı
anlamaya başlamıştım ve Çünkü konuşmaya
ve kendini anlatabilme başlamıştım
mesela o zaman dedim ki niye yapıyorum
ben bunu bu para kazanmam lazım Ama
neden böyle şeylerle uğraşıyorum işte
aslında burada şimdi bir çok genç
arkadaşımız var sahnenin arkasında çok
heyecanlı çok çaba sarf eden genç
arkadaşlarımıza Evet teki Bu kaydı daha
sonra izleyecek olan genç arkadaşlarımız
var bu soruları sorduğunuz anlara dikkat
edin Neden bunlar benim başıma geliyor
Niye ben bunları yaşıyorum Niye bu kadar
zorlanmak zorundayım gibi sorular
sordunuz ama bilin ki sizin hikayenizde
önemli şeyler oluyor ve ben bu şekilde
üniversiteyi bitirip pazarlama
yöneticisi oldum bir alışveriş
merkezinde Alışveriş Merkezi Johnson
meselin yönetimindeydi o yönetimin
Aslında sahiplerinden bir tanesi Az önce
Benden önce sahnedeydi onu da söylemedim
bir sürpriz olacak Hayat Hikayemiz de
bir kesişme var dedim Yani anlatmak
istediğim şey şu
noktaları geriye dönerek birleştiriyor
suzama
en ileri baktığınızda Aslında
hikayenizde karşılaştırıyor sunuz burada
bir şey çıkıyor inanmamız lazım
yani sadece hayal etmek hiçbir zaman
yeterli değil bazen öyle anlar oluyor ki
işte sizi çok seven insanlar size çok
yakın insanlar sizin ailenizden olan
insanlar size inanmayı durdurabiliyor
Çünkü bu zor bir şey ama sizin her şeye
rağmen kendimize inanmamız lazım Ben
dedim ki pazarlama yöneticiliği çok
güzel ama ama ama
yaratıcılığımı hiç kullanamıyorum ve her
gün aynı şeyi yapıyorum ve tek bir marka
için yapıyorum ve ki ben nasıl
yaratıcılığımı kullanabilirim O zaman
işte çeşitli kurslara gitmeye başladım
ve gittiğim bir kursta bir arkadaşım
bana dedi ki sen neden reklamcı
olmuyorsun Ben dedim ki A evet Neden ben
reklamcı oluyor Hadi O Zaman reklamcı
olayım işte Özgeçmişimi hazırladım 40
tane Ajans çıkarttım başvurumu
hazırladım falan gönderdim önce hiç ses
çıkmadı Ondan sonra bir iki görüşmeye
katıldım Şimdi bana hep diyorlar ki
Harika süper birisin Çok işte çok iyi
şeyler yapmışsın ama biz seni direkt
başlatmayı stajyer olman lazım stajyer
olunca da para yok Ya
ben dedim ki Nasıl oldu 28 yaşındayım
zaten o kadar şey yaşadım ancak rahat
etmiştim yöneticiliği bırakıp geliyorum
Yani birazcık falan yok hayır sonra
ilginç bir şey oldu biraz daha dedim ben
araştırayım bu Reklamcılık sektörünü bir
Galatasaray Üniversitesi'nde bir
reklamcı dinlemeye gittim
Ondan sonra baktım kimse soru sormuyor
Tabi ben hemen soru sordum Dedim ki ben
böyle bir şey istiyorum ama Bana
diyorlar ki stajyer olman lazım ne
yapmam gerekiyor o dedi ki bana kendini
saat
Evet bu da mı dedim evet dedi Hemen
şimdi bir de tabii ki dedi Siz dedim
nasıl yapıyorsunuz Biz üstüne biraz
çalışıyoruz dedi Ben de biraz çalışayım
o zaman dedim çıktım ama İzmit'e gitmem
lazım Ortaköy'den Beşiktaş'a yürüyorum
ve vapura tam ayağıma atarken tabi bütün
yol boyunca kurdum kendimi sinirliyim
diyorum ki Neden olmuyor Keşke birileri
tanıyor olsaydım Hayat Benim için bu
kadar Neden zor falan tam böyle bu
program atıyorum dedim ki ya adamı
Gerçekten insanlıktan çıkartıyorlar
ve sonra aklıma bunu bir konsept olarak
kullanma Fikri geldi dedim ki ben
hayvanları kullanayım Ondan sonra işte
Mesela çölde tozu tarak koşan bir fil
dedim ki her şartta işe gelirim
taksinin içinde oturmuş başını uzatmış
Bir zürafa her şeyi merak ederim Ne
eğitimle ilgili ne yaptım Bugün sizlerle
ilgili ne bildiğim yabancı hiçbir şey
yazmamış Sadece bu özellikleri Eğer
böyle bir ile çalışmak istiyorsanız İşte
bu numaradan bana ulaşabilirsiniz diye
oradan bir süre geçti hiçbir ses yok o
zaman dedim ki Elif senin hadi olmayacak
yani Reklamcılık hikayenin burada
bitmesi lazım ve sonra
ama hiç başvurmadım ve asla da girmemiz
mümkün olmayacağı bir ajanstan kendim
teklif aldım benim girdiğim yok 650 kişi
başvurmuştu ve beyinlerine elektrot
dayadılar reklamcılığı ne kadar
seviyorsun diye bana bu soru sorulmadı
Çünkü ben aslında hayatta zorlandım bir
anı yaratıcı bir fikre dönüştürerek
biraz daha onlardan öne geçmiş oldum
Reklamcılık kariyerin başladıktan kısa
süre sonra da bir Araştırma Şirketine
geçtim Çünkü stratejide kendimi
güçlendirmek gerektiğini düşünüyordum
hemen yönetici oldu çünkü öneriler
soruyordum onu öyle yapmasak da böyle
yapsak nasıl olur diye bu olmadı Bana
diyorlardı ki Tamam o zaman sen bunları
yap biz görelim
jean-marie Duru TV'de blin çok önemli
stratejin başında olan adamlarından biri
o Türkiye'ye geldiği yıl az önce ağabey
beyin bahsettiği caksa kalanı da aynı
gün sunumu vardı işte başka bir ajanstan
teklif aldım oraya geçtim dedim küçük
benim dijital öğrenmem lazım ondan sonra
bir yıl dijital de çalıştıktan sonra
yabancı yatırımcılar geliyor çok büyük
bir proje olacak ve onun burada
yönetilmesi lazım Ne dersin dediler mı
başka bir ajansa transfer oldum yani
asla hiç başvurmadan stajyer olarak
alınarak böyle hani olmaz falan denilen
yerde üç yıl boyunca hiç başvurmadan
işte Türkiye'nin en yaşantısında çalışan
bir insan oldu Sonra baktım ki aslında
reklamcılığın bir yere gittiği yok
istediğim tam olarak burada değilmiş
Dünya çok başka bir yer haline geliyor
ve bizim bunları tasarlayan insanlar
olarak biraz daha önden gitmemiz lazım
ama mevcut sistem o kadar çok yüklenmiş
ki bize bunu mümkün kılmıyor tabi hemen
Buket'e gittim ve huzurlu
orada aradım istifa ettim dedim ki ben
artık reklamcı olmak istemiyorum biraz
ara vereceğim ya reklamcılığı bırakınca
Restoran açıyorsunuz ya da işte dünya
geziyorsunuz dedim ki ben biraz dünyayı
gezeyim Orada gezerken bazı şeyleri
düşünme fırsatım oldu Bir ara Buraya
geldim bir pazarlama zirvesinde böyle
bir sunum gerçekleştirdim Ondan sonra
tekrar biraz gittim gezdim Bu da
Belçika'da dünyanın en küçük kenti o
kadar küçük ki 10 dakika yürüdüğünüzde
bitiyor ama ortaçağdan kalma çok güzel
bir mimarisi var sizinlede paylaşmak
istedim buraları artık biraz hızlı
gezeceğim
ve bir süre sonra dedim ki
he tamam Tükendim
ve o şimdi artık iyisin gezdirin Yeni
insanlar tanıdığım farklı kültürler
gördüm dünyada yeni neler oluyor Onların
farkındasın Şimdi bir şey yapman lazım
Bu bizim Samet'le birlikte Kardeşimle
birlikte şirketi kurduktan sonra hemen
gidip bir heves tuttuğumuz ilk ofisimiz
beş buçuk metre kare ya çok büyük
hayallerle girdik Bak bu kapıdan öyle
söyleyeyim
tabii Mesela işte Samet şey taşıyor
sırtında tahta mızı taşıyor Çünkü her
şeyine kendimiz yapıyoruz yani Bir Hayal
kurduk yola çıktık dedi ki Türkiye'de ve
dünyada bir şeyleri artık farklı
yapmamız lazım artık markalar sadece
iletişimle sorunlarını çözemezler iş
modellerine bakmamız lazım ve kökten bir
verimli sunum Sun çözüm sunmamız lazım
bu noktada geliştirdiğimiz modeli
Türkiye'nin anlaması çok mümkün olmadı
Çünkü yeni bir şey yaptığımızda
anlaşılmak her zaman ne oluyor yenilik
yapmak çok zor bir şey
çünkü işte insanlara değişiklik sever
misin dediğimde herkese ki A Evet
bayılırım değişikliği Nesi kötü ki ama
işte artık orada oturma burada otur
dediğinde biraz Panikleme başlar bir
şeyi artık öyle değil böyle yapman
gerekiyor dediğinde
çok hoşuna gitmez bu durum ve biz bu
durumla karşı karşıya kaldık bir şekilde
Samet bu arada ortam Kardeşler iş yapma
dediler ama inanılmaz şanslıyım hem çok
iyi bir insan hem de çok yetenekli bir
perakende satış konusunda uzmandır
Kendisi böyle göründüğüne bakmayın Belki
de bana kızacak neden daha Karizmatik
bir fotoğrafını koyma diye koymadım diye
ama hayattaki Gerçekler acıdır Samet çim
şimdi bu bizim ilk gültenim islanmis Az
önce bizi sunarken de bahsettiler Çok
teşekkür ederim bu Gülten nasıl doğdu
biliyor musunuz 26 ülkede 3000'den şu an
dokuduğu Gülten Bir yıl boyunca uğraştık
beş kuruş paramız kalmadı çalışıyoruz
çalışıyoruz olmuyor bütün birikimimizi
bu işe yatırdık insanlar bizi
anlamıyorlar tam yüzdük yüzdük kuyruğuna
geldik Bir müşteriyle anlaşıyoruz derken
sözleşmeler imzalanıyor Yani o kadar
anlaşıyoruz dedik yani olmuyor
vb o zaman dedim ki
var ya şu anda bırakacaksın ya da Devam
etmenin bir yolunu bulacaksın şimdi o
zaman şu soruyu sordum bu insanların
bizi anlamasının sebebi Yani bir biz
anlatamamış olabiliriz iki gerçekten
kapasiteleri olmayabilir ama belki de
yeterli bilgi ve ilhamı alamadıkları
için de bizi anlamıyo olabilirler O
zaman biz onlara bazı bilgiler
gönderelim ve onlara biraz zaman verelim
onlar da bize artık Almasınlar şimdi bu
ilk haliydi bu sonra geldiği hale
Samet'le işler yolunda gitti ilk
yurtdışı müşterimize gittik ve akşamları
mızı yaptık Sonra dedi ki insanlar lazım
işte okusunlar hired listede mutlaka
duymaları gereken şeyleri anlatalım
konuşalım Elif'in al oradaki partnerim
Onunla beraber yapıyoruz konuşmaya Çünkü
tek başına konuşmak bir süre sonra
arkamdan işler gerçekten imkansız hale
gelebiliyor ve O da Yolumuz Cüneyt
Özdemir ile kesişti Herkes çok merak
ediyorum nasıl oldu Nasıl oldu Nasıl
oldu işte hamburger yaparak oldu tişört
katlayarak oldu ve ondan sonra da birçok
zorluğun üstesinden gelmeyi
becerek oldu başararak demeyeceğim çünkü
başarı ile ilgili bir sözü var Onu sona
sakladım şu anda Geldiğimiz noktada
bütün dünyayı gerçek zamanlı tarıyoruz
diyebilirim yani teknoloji ve gelecekle
ilgili ne varsa Bize Sorun biz size
söyleyelim Bu bize çok güçlü yetenekler
kazandırıyor mu biz bunları yine
ülkemizde geri vermek istiyoruz Ticaret
Odası'nın bir etkinliğine katıldığımız
da bizi biraz üzen yolculuğumuzun biraz
daha gururlu bir hale gelmiş şeklini
görüyorsunuz burada Evet şimdi her yolcu
geç her yolculuk geçmişten başlar
demiştik Ben sizi biraz geçmişimden
bahsettim bu yolculuk beni bugün buraya
getirdi ama size şunu söylemek istiyorum
son olarak dalay Lama diyor ki o kadar
tükete gittik Biraz oradan alıntı
yapalım değil mi
mi başarılarınızı onları elde etmek için
neler feda ettiğiniz ve ölçü yani
birşeyleri kazanmak için Muhakkak bir
şeyleri kaybetmez gerekir hayatta ne
kadar kaybetmeye hazırsınız neleri
kaybetmeye alırsınız onları kaybettikten
sonra ne kadar kazanacaksınız işte
aslında geriye kalan tam olarak da bu
Teşekkür ederim